les uns concentrez-vous le premier qui
rigole a perdu lass rasseoir attention
on commence par benjamin c'est nul
mathieu et pourquoi tu arrive bientôt tu
as la chance de physiquement est
avantagé le quittais mon narcissique
mauvaise vous avez des financements
publics des jambes propos à manassas
delphine ne va pas pouvoir faire de 1
600 que ça va être un moment triste
c'est toi pas trop soir à temps isabelle
est une autre lorsque gilles peut
retourner la situation
bon ben alors on y va j'en arrive à rire
sérieuse à sérieux de sérieux bizot
ballet izzat al et donne tout son
ensemble
[Rires]
allez encore il a tu peux tu peux vas-y
ouais je crois qu'on vient tout seul
et on sort notre joker déshabille toi
fais l'éléphant faut commencer par
gilles parce que c'est le deuxième qui
rigole tout le temps c'est parce que
france alors on commence même prem's
était sont pas drôles et vont maintenant
mais c'est parce qu'il a beaucoup d'os
non mais il faut faire une grimace quand
même on est en prime time
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
google est même passée